and welcome I'm Ian Shapiro
currently director of
and one of the pre
with that as my illustrious predecessors
here now is that you get to not only
introduce the coca-cola lecture every
year but actually to decide who it
should be and to invite that person and
I'm delighted to have Michael Doyle here
today he's actually giving the 15th
annual coca-cola world fund lecture at
Yale was established in 1992 to support
endeavours among specialists in the
intersection between international
relations international law the
management of international enterprises
and organizations it's hard to think of
anyone who fits that bill better than
Michael Doyle we co-sponsor this event
along with the law school and the School
of Management Michael Doyle is the
Harold Brown professor of US foreign
policy and security policy at Columbia
before coming to Columbia he was a
professor of politics and international
affairs at Princeton though for two
years he was on leave to work as the UN
secretary-general kofi annan special
advisor professor Doyle was also the
George
nursey visiting professor at the Yale
Law School in 2006 and 2007 so he's a
well known figure on campus and part of
my agenda in bringing him here today is
to ensure that he continues to be a
well-known face around town how to
introduce Michael there are many ways
that it could be done I'm a believer in
short introductions because whatever
brought people here today was not to
listen to me I will say that he is a
Renaissance intellect equally at home
I think in discussing the classics of
political philosophy and fine grained
questions of national security strategy
and tactic
he's written many books my the earliest
one that came to my attention was a
fabulous book about empires that he
published in 1986 it's more recent books
ways of war and peace most recently and
of course making war and building peace
which he wrote with Nicholas Sam banners
are one of our own professors of
international relations he is not yet
published although it exists but
technically not yet published this book
striking first which is actually a
debate among or among I should say
several theorists of international
relations and Michael on the subject of
preemption and he's going to be partly
drawing on that book that will be
published you said at the end of this
month I think yeah by Princeton
University Press called striking first
and indeed the lecture the title of
today's lectures is drawn from that
striking first the law and politics of
preemption and preventive force so I'm
pleased to introduce professor Michael
Doyle
Thank You Ian for that very generous
introduction it's a it's a real pleasure
to be here to give the coca-cola lecture
I don't know how many of your lecturers
have said that they hope this is the
real thing
and I would say that as well but you've
probably heard that too many times it
draws upon the book striking first and
some Tanner lectures that I gave it
Princeton a year or so ago and the
question that I'd like to address with
you is the issue of when states should
be permitted to go to war by which I
mean to use force or to use mandatory
sanctions and blockades before they have
been attacked and for the purpose of
protecting themselves that's the issue
in March of 2003 we all know the US and
a Coalition of the Willing
invaded Iraq partly they said to enforce
Security Council law and partly I quote
to defeat enemies abroad before they
attack us at home were they right to do
so today some are speculating about how
to prevent North Korea from expanding
its nuclear arsenal or Iran from
acquiring nuclear weapons so these are
controversial and consequential topics
my topic is therefore straightforward
but the answers are distinctly
controversial that I'll be giving indeed
talking about preventive war in the
aftermath of Iraq makes me feel as if I
were questioning the survivors of the
Titanic on their lifeboats about how
they felt about ocean travel the fiasco
of Iraq colors.every discussion I think
of prevention today you won't be
surprised to hear therefore that my
version of these answers that will be in
this book striking first or tentative I
think they're over all right but I'm not
absolutely sure they're right but what I
would suggest to you and here's the last
sales pitch that I offer for the book
that it the book itself is a mod
of the kind of deliberation that I think
is essential if we are going to come to
an adequate understanding as citizens
and officials of the problem with
prevention because not only does it
include my lectures in it but it
includes a deeply engaged
sometimes critical sometimes supportive
set of essays by three superb scholars
Dean Harold Co here from Yale Professor
Richard tuck and Professor Jeffrey
McMann so if the right attitude towards
prevention is difficult deliberation
which in my view it is my last sales
pitch for the book you will find four
three views in that book four views in
that book that give you a great
introduction to the difficulties so my
question focuses on what the law is and
what it should be the ethics and
politics of the law of pre-emptive and
preventive self-defense I start with the
problem that is existing law as I see it
and existing doctrines are inadequate
and I'll tell you why I think that's the
case and then my aim in the second half
of the lecture is to propose four
standards for judging the difficult
issues of prevention and my view is if
these standards were adopted we would do
better we would be better equipped to
face the very difficult decisions that
we have faced and done not so well and
will face in the near future when it
comes to the use of force so let me
start with the problems then I'll move
to my four standards there are two
problems with the status quo the first
problem is that the substantive rules
and standards that we have are not or
not good and the second problem is that
the procedural standards are also not
good but still we need some standards
let me just let me elaborate first on
the substantive rules and doctrines
conventionally states must wait as the
international law currently holds for an
armed attack to occur and this is
article 51 of the UN Charter or to be so
very imminent almost about to occur that
it is nearly instantaneous and under
those circumstances they can
forced to defend themselves so an armed
attack must be already in place across a
border or it must be extremely imminent
and under those circumstances one can
use force the origin of this standard
goes back to the Caroline case 1837 1841
a case between the British Empire and
the United States over a dispute up on
the New York border it was eventually
resolved by notes between Secretary of
State Daniel Webster and the British
envoy Lloyd Ashburton the issue was that
American rebels
excuse-me American citizens were aiding
Canadian rebels across the border in
providing them with arms and materiel
and the British concerned about this
rebellion that was going on crossed the
Niagara and seized this u.s. boat burned
it killed an American citizen or to lit
it on fire pushed it out in the river
and went over Niagara Falls we objected
to this attack upon our territory and
the question then rose was it
justifiable or not Daniel Webster Corps
said no the British foreign the Foreign
Minister said yes he said that one had
to be able to act preemptively in order
to protect territory or international
chaos would ensue in the end they've
sent note backs back and forth event in
the end they agreed to continue
disagreeing that is Webster never
accepted the British view that this was
legitimate and the British never
accepted this the US view that this was
an act of aggression against the United
States
so they disagreed upon the facts so to
speak but what they agreed upon was a
standard that then became the gold
standard for pre-emptive self-defense
and the standard was that the threat had
to be overwhelming here I quote in its
necessity leaving quote no choice of
means and not even a moment no moment
for deliberation and that became the
standards of when you could use force
before you're attacked now the
resolution of this beaut was convenient
the US and the British Empire had much
bigger fish to fry in the late 1830s the
northern border of the US but the
standard that it was set up I would
suggest was not very useful it was not
very useful because it was too extreme
to extreme to deal with real-life
real-world emergencies it's useful to
rule out arbitrary use as a force for
any purpose but it's not good to define
the circumstances under which you might
want to preemptively use force it
required the no moment for deliberation
no alternative means overwhelming those
were a little too strict when you go
through history and I was looking for
examples you know if this is a good rule
sometimes it will say don't preempt and
other times you'll say to preempt i
couldn't find a single case that met the
standards that would be a legitimate
preemption since 1840 the closest one
was the netherlands in 1941 what was
about to be attacked by japan but even
then the Netherlands had very bad
information and it turned out that
wasn't really a threat as they saw it
imminently it took place a week later
the attack on the Netherlands that
doesn't mean they shouldn't have
declared war as another ones did on
Japan it just meant that even under this
circumstance so justifiable attack was
coming the pure standards of Caroline
are too extreme to provide a window of
justification for it so that's one
problem another problem with that
standard is that it's rejected by the
single most powerful country in the
world today that is the United States
and President Bush has made it clear
that preemption these standards of
preemption are not ones that the United
States has prepared to follow he says
that instead the United States should
follow a doctrine of prevention
future-oriented
anticipation of threats and he'll none
ciated this in a famous doctrine
obviously now called the Bush Doctrine
where he set that forward and he had an
afford brag On June 28th of 2005 he
enunciated this doctrine about the need
to eliminate potential threats that are
grave and growing and let me quote the
president after September the 11th I
made a commitment to the American people
this nation will not wait to be attacked
again many terrorists who kill innocent
men women and children on the streets of
Baghdad are followers of the same
murderous ideology that took the lives
of our citizens in New York and
Washington and Pennsylvania there is
only one course of action against them
to defeat them abroad before they attack
us at home so that's the Bush Doctrine
now some people including myself might
be tempted to dismiss this as simple ska
flowing by the administration they could
care less about law so they care less
about this law but I think that would be
too quick because there are some
circumstances in the modern world that I
think would lead us to want to rethink
the Carolinian standards of extreme
imminence as the right determination as
to when force can be used I think for
example that some contemporary threats
including weapons of mass destruction
in the hands of suicide terrorists or
States embarked upon genocide 'old
projects or planning imperial aggression
with weapons of mass destruction across
state borders these kinds of threats
differ from the kinds of threats that
would be readily deterred ex-ante or
defeated at acceptable cost after they
occurred
Caroline was too extreme for 18:37 it's
in my view way too extreme for our own
times today some threats we should note
however can be safely appeased not all
threats need to be confronted China was
safely appeased in the 1970s and 80s for
many other threats deterrence will work
to block any massive attack but
deterrence may not work comprehensively
that is across the board for all the
relations that count Saddam Hussein for
example was rationally deterred from
using weapons of mass destruction on US
forces in Israel in 1990 and there is no
reason that I have seen to believe that
he would not have stayed deterred from
similar attacks on the US or Israel
anytime during the 1990s up through our
own time as long as his regime survived
he knew very well that both his regime
and himself was very much at stake if he
were to
attacked the US or Israel nonetheless
it's also my view that continuing to
prevent him from acquiring a robust
ability in the weapons of mass
destruction nuclear biological or
chemical particularly one with
international intercontinental reach was
a worthwhile thing to do it was
worthwhile trying to prevent him from
acquiring those weapons why Assad
Hussein with imperial ambitions and WMD
would have been a constant threat to his
neighbors whom he might have
successfully intimidated and a constant
source of brinksmanship he would have
been I think impossible to dislodge from
Kuwait in 1990 at acceptable cost in
lives if he had in 1990 a deliverable
system of nuclear weapons available to
himself he would still be there and that
would be very problematic dangerous bad
for us the world's economy and of course
the Middle East
moreover moving to another group a
variety of extremist non-state actors
using terrorist tactics or another group
that's beyond the scope of simple
deterrence al Qaeda the Tamil Tigers
the various al Qaeda offshoots offshoots
and the various affiliates attached to
them have adopted suicide terrorism as a
tactic by definition suicide terrorists
are very hard to deter may be known to
turrible
they are also hard to deny that it's
hard to keep them out of your countries
because of the small scale to covert
actions the ability to penetrate small
and liberal states that have relatively
open borders in the way that the 9/11
attack errs did more overt even though
they kill small numbers these terrorists
3 only 3,000 were killed on 9/11 and
much smaller numbers in Bali Madrid
London but but allowing and not
preventing those kinds of attacks to the
extent that one can is debilitating for
societies and especially democratic
societies now a death is a death but
murder is not the same thing as a
traffic accident and States must act to
protect their citizens become becoming
the undefended prey of mass murderers
prevention thus is one recourse that we
should not take
the table so my argument here is there
is something to be concerned about
provided that we act carefully
deliberately legally where possible with
adequate information and proportionally
all the same saying that there is
something to that Bush concerned about
potentially aggressive imperialist
states and about the danger of of
terrorists that does not mean that the
Bush Doctrine is in my mind a valuable
contribution or a justifiable
contribution to international security
and/or international standards or law
the problem is that allowing one state
to adopt an inherently subjective
standard ie the threats it happens to
perceive is an invitation to chaos
whether because that state itself abuses
it or other states take that as a
license to do exactly the same thing on
their own and operate on the same basis
whenever they feel threatened feel free
to be able to use force in that latter
case unless magically all states happen
to agree upon the nature of threats
which is very unlikely we will find a
situation where some states are
pre-empting the preventive actions of
other states if everyone can agree just
to based upon their own perceptions
right now for example the administration
considers Iran's nuclear program to be a
threat and the Iranian regime known
undoubtedly considers the bush regime to
be a threat or each accorded thereby the
right to attack each other that's the
danger of a subjectivist understanding
of these kinds of threats so let me sum
up so far subtly I think we face serious
threats that are not readily deterred
some threats are deter well but others
are not and we are stuck with a legal
rule the Carolyne that is too narrow
that doesn't allow us to act in some
degree with adequate foresight in action
and a bush doctrine that is much too
broad that's where I think we're stuck
when it comes to substitute rules let's
move them to procedural rules and see if
we can find something there that will
assist us the usual way that social
scientists and legal scholars address
problems of ex ante that is
for the hand uncertainty or the danger
of exploitability that actions will be
taken that are purely self-serving oh is
through procedural rules which improve
the liberation we subject these
judgments these that are being made to
structure deliberation and contestation
that is debate in the presence of other
decision makers in the classic flavor a
z' to elicit a decent respect for the
opinion of mankind so it's through the
procedural rule that one corrects
potential abuses of substantive
standards that are not adequate when we
have difficult decisions it's important
that they be deliberated and have the
support of diverse social systems that
is people coming from different
societies ideologies levels of income
when they do they tend to become more
rational that is if the same arguments
can meet the assent of people coming
from diverse backgrounds other things
equal they're likely to have a stronger
rational basis moreover you're important
about deliberation is that it mobilizes
a coalition to support you those who
agree so for both these reasons
deliberation is extraordinarily
important fortunately the international
legal system has already included just
such a procedural system of judgment
unilateral prevention is illegal it does
not enjoy legal status but multilateral
decisions that are embedded in the
United Nations Security Council in UN
Charter chapter 4 gives the council the
a decision process and the authority to
determine I quote any threat to the
peace breach of the peace act of
aggression and to take whatever action
including coercive embargoes and
forcible measures by land air or sea
that it sees fit then as we've built in
a procedural rule
for determining when prevention is legal
and it's legal when it is multilateral
unilaterally we can preempt in
Carolinian circumstances unilaterally
prevention is illegal but multilateral
prevention is fully legal provided it
meets the framework of Security Council
decision-making and moreover a decision
taking in the Security Council it's not
a recommendation it's legally binding on
all the members of the United Nations so
we have a powerful procedural mechanism
to deal with prevention fully authorized
fully legal no question about it all you
need however is nine out of the 15 votes
on the Security Council including no
vetoes from the US Russia France UK or
China and then you have a fully legal
preventive action so that's the
procedural solution that exists I think
it's a neat solution and I'm gonna
defend it in the second half of my talk
very strongly but let me just mention
two problems to start with first problem
with the Security Council is that the
Security Council has in numerous
instances in the past behaved
irresponsibly it's failed to decide on
the use of force when it was arguably
the right thing to do you could look for
example to various humanitarian
interventions that should have taken
place a much stronger intervention in
Bosnia an intervention in Rwanda an
authorization for Kosovo maybe even some
say Darfur today though I find that more
questionable it has not acted
responsibly in a wide range of
circumstances when force arguably should
have been authorized and second of all
the reason why we can't just rely upon
procedure is that the Security Council
itself lacks
subjective standards to guide its
deliberations concerning when it should
authorize preventive force and when not
it itself has to have some standards to
decide when to vote yes and when to vote
no and at the present time there are no
such standards so what I've got two so
far in this part prevention is legal but
only it's only when it's at the Security
Council we need substantive standards
number one to guide the Security
Council's deliberations and number two
it's a secure
Council acts irresponsibly to think
about whether one should act without a
Security Council procedural okay that's
that's the problems that I see let me
now turn to the solutions I will try to
fill in the gaps between the dangers of
the narrowness of Caroline and the
excess broadness the excess subjectivism
of the Bush Doctrine and the problem of
the security council's lack of reliable
procedural authorization I want to try
to fill that in with some substantive
standards and some procedural standards
that will give us together a better
framework to make decisions about the
use of force that's my that's my aim I'm
going to develop these standards for you
briefly yeah in the book I have a number
of case studies that illustrate them one
is the Security Council sanctions
against South Africa in 1977 which I
think it was both legal and justifiable
then I also talked about the Cuban
Missile Crisis of 1962 and the Israeli
attack on the on the Iraqi nuclear
reactor Atos Iraq in 1981 these last two
from the international law point of view
were illegal but I think justifiable
that a Security Council didn't approve
them but they were in an argument that
make to you or justifiable I'm not going
to do that here but I'd be happy to take
any questions you might have about those
cases what I want to do is focus on the
standards and then take a look a little
bit back to the Iraq case and explain to
you why I think Iraq was not a case of
justifiable prevention first of all the
standards preventive standards need to
look beyond imminence because that's
what prevention is about it's looking
over the horizon at a threat that isn't
absolutely immediate at the present time
an attack that's taking place and which
of those standards be I'd suggested the
way that we can develop jurisprudence of
understanding when the use of force
might be justifiable is to borrow from a
lot of just war doctrine and look at the
nature of the threat that is how lethal
is it
what's the likelihood that it will occur
and to what extent can we find
legitimate action that incorporates
standards of proportionality necessity
to liberation so that we can avoid rash
decisions and to what extent can we
reintroduce the role of law as a
signaler and governing mechanism in
making these hard decisions so I want to
outline those four l's conveniently all
ELLs lethality likelihood legitimacy and
legality mythology is is straightforward
it measures how many people are likely
to die that's that's the most obvious
but there are other concerns that might
might have extremely valued property for
example Notre Dame in France is not any
old Church the US Capitol is not any old
marble building Kyoto and Japan was not
any other Japanese City and even the the
decision horrible decision to drop the
atomic bombs in 1945 took that into
account instead they dropped it on
innocent Hiroshima and Nagasaki but at
any rate lethality is the key measure
lives of the measure that one wants to
be concerned about the anticipated harm
to lives the second standard gets much
more complicated and that's likelihood
and we in international relations have
two broad theoretical templates in which
we try to assess the the likelihood of
war one of them is the old realism where
relative capabilities are the key
concern this goes all the way back to
lucidity who made an argument famously
that war is always likely but it's
especially likely when power balances
are changing when some status quo power
sees a rising power about to take it
over and dominate it under those
circumstances the status quo power is
going to very likely to want to use
force to prevent it being overtaken by
stronger power and some Thucydides long
ago made the argument that what made war
inevitable between Athens and Sparta was
the growth of Athenian power and the
fear which this caused in Sparta that he
saw as the essence
that war so changing power balances for
the realist war is always possible it
becomes likely when one state begins to
overtake another liberalism another big
philosophy of world politics focuses on
institutionalized intentions and regimes
in the 18th century the famous German
philosopher Immanuel Kant made an
argument that liberal Republic's could
establish a self-sustaining peace
amongst themselves that is there would
be peace among fellow liberal publics it
was the non Republic some monarchs and
the autocrats that posed the danger that
would be experienced and they were the
ones most likely to start a war now both
these philosophies have their strengths
and in other context I've defended them
both but they're not the best guideline
for understanding the preventive use of
force against realism for example
changing power balances don't always
lead to war the u.s. surpassed Britain
in the late 19th century and maintained
peace with it maintain peace with it and
against liberalism dictators and
autocrats and monarchs don't always
engage in force the typical dictatorship
as a matter of fact rarely provokes a
war they sometimes do but only rarely so
adopting either the realist model or the
liberal model of threatened likelihood
would lead us into far too many false
positives that is preventive wars
against threats that really would not
have materialized so what we need to do
is look at more practical assessments of
likelihood we need to move from grand
philosophy into more nuanced historical
interpretations we need to look at
things for example that include past
aggressive behavior what's the record
looked like announced threats it makes a
difference if a statesman goes around
threatening to wipe a country off the
map
in addition to factors of capability and
power we need to look in this much more
nuanced way to give you two examples of
this in a discussion of the 1967 war
between Israel and Egypt
Michael Walter a political philosopher
identified the circumstances that he
thought justified Israel's attack on
Egypt even though a war was not imminent
he made an argument that one could find
a manifest
intent to injure on the part of the
statements made by the Egyptian
government not to speak of the closing
of the Straits of Tiran to Israeli
shipping found active preparations that
is they were mobilizing their forces and
moving their armies around on the
Israel's borders and an increasing
danger the third factor that is that
Israel didn't couldn't find the
mobilization that had engaged in to meet
this threat sustainable Israeli army
couldn't stay as a citizen army stay
fully mobilized and under those
circumstances Walter says even though
you can't say that the Egyptians were
you know instantly without a time for
deliberation about to attack Egypt
nonetheless he argues it was justifiable
if we go further back we can find other
standards the great legal philosopher
emmerich DeVoe tel argued in the 18th
century that you should look for a
pattern of rapacious eighteenth-century
vocabulary behavior and if you if you
see that attach to a significant
increase in power and the side that is
the threatening side is unwilling to
give guarantees of peaceful behavior
once it's asked put those three things
together and Vitello said you could have
a justifiable preventive war so my
recommendation is that an assessing
likelihood we need to focus much more on
these historical nuanced behavior
patterns on announced intentions on
patterns of behavior and from the
Liberals I think we should assume by and
large that fellow Democrats won't be
attacking each other and not be
concerned with increases in capacity in
their hands but from the realist we
borrow the view that's very important to
pay attention to increases in capacity
that are attached to these aggressive
patterns of behavior and aggressive
intentions and nuclear proliferation is
one such increasing capacity it
naturally attracts attention if I turn
to my third standard the third standard
is legitimacy it's not enough just to
look at lafalot II and likelihood that
that quality of the threat we also need
to be concerned about the kind of
remedies or responses and some being
better than others it's very important
to be proportional that is
not to do more harm than what you're in
that what you're trying to avoid the
benefits in cost much that must in some
sense be justifiable one has to limit
the response to what's minimally
necessary that is you can't use a threat
as an excuse to run a rampage and lastly
one needs relevant deliberation in a
multilateral forum or in some other
forum to improve the quality decisions
these make decisions legitimate that
otherwise would not be legitimate even
if a real threat is there on the horizon
proportionality is extremely important
there's all sorts of different responses
you can take to a threat and the
response has to be proportional to the
kind of threat you're facing and an
effectively designed to deal with it
that is there are plenty of threats out
there but that doesn't mean is that's a
license to invade transform occupy a
country if that threat could well be
dealt with by let us say multilateral
economic sanctions or a blockade or a
surgical strike you need to take the
least harmful measure that deals with
the extent of the threat that's being
faced furthermore there's good arguments
that's when we look at necessity to say
that if you don't need to act now that
is that the threat is not increasing
there's good reasons to wait time often
cures threats and problems in world
politics if you don't have a good case
for acting now if you wait who knows the
threatening statesmen may may may kick
the bucket and a better successor coming
into power if you're not if you don't
need to act now one shouldn't act now
that's another standard of
proportionality and lastly deliberation
it's really important that however this
decision was made it be made with the
maximum amount of deliberation the
dangers of groupthink and self-motivated
information are prevalent in all of
international politics exposing your
views to the contestation of others in
various fora is a good protection
against that not a guarantee but a
protection and that has to be done that
moves me then to the last standard
because one of the best protections
against groupthink and self-motivated
evidence is running your decision
through a framework of international law
that is paying special attention to the
ways in which the threatening power has
or has not violated international law
the egregious violation of international
law is itself a signal of aggressive
intent and what it should be taking is
such these are rules that have been
agreed on for a long time
states that explicitly and regularly and
consistently go out to break them are
signaling their unwillingness to live
with their neighbors and so that I think
is an important standard so if you see a
regime that's violated the international
law and its regular behavior a record of
aggression for example egregious human
rights violations posing threats for
example it themselves illegal under the
UN Charter a quit acquiring capabilities
in violation of its undertakings for the
non-proliferation treaty
these themselves should be seen as a
significant signal of increasing threat
the other part where law plays a strong
role is in the legality of the remedy
it's very important for the sake of
international order that one pursues
one's remedy within the framework of law
doing what is legal in the first
instance as a way to deal with the
threat and most importantly therefore it
means and here I mentioned that point
that I started with going back to the
Security Council that is the place that
can legally authorized any form of
prevention
if the Iraq war had gone through a
Security Council vote it still might
have been an unwise or stupid but it
would have been fully legal and operated
within the framework of a law of the law
signals to all the members of the
international community that the rules
are ones that can be relied upon and
that they can if they if they abide by
the law themselves have a safe harbor of
safety this is this is a high value to
legalization so my argument then and is
that one needs to go back to the
Security Council no act of prevention
should take place without a roof first
resort to the security council some
scholars say don't take something to the
Security Council just because it'll
embarrass it like during the Kosovo war
don't take that issue there because we
knew the Russians were gonna veto it I
say take it there and make sure the
Russians are forced to veto it so that
you signal your willingness to abide by
the procedures which are the legitimate
ones for exercising the use of force and
at the Security Council meeting it
should be on the record not off the
record every member should be expected
to state its reasons either for
favouring a request to use preventive
force or for rejecting it we should
begin to develop this jurisprudence of
standards which will be which will
justify the particular case and create a
jurisprudence of rules that will be
useful elsewhere so that's going back to
the Security Council I think is step one
step two but given the veto possessed by
the super powers and the less than
perfect reliability of any procedural
standard including the Security Council
including this history the Security
Council can't be the only resort for the
authorization of force for the decision
to use force some in some cases one one
will have to go outside the Security
Council the Security Council is acting
irresponsibly and I think at that point
one needs to have two other procedural
mechanisms if one is to go unilaterally
or regionally to the OAS or NATO or
elsewhere to look for an authorization
at that point you've stepped outside the
law
but one should not step outside the
process of deliberation so it's vitally
important that there be a full
investigation it should be a national
commission that looks into the decisions
taken in order to assess whether it's
the correct decision oh and second of
all either ex ante if with there's time
or ex post if there's a time pressure
and lastly there needs to be an
international commission if the Security
Council does not authorize and some
state or regional body NATO the OAS or
other use force and the International
Commission should be set up that
investigates and comes to
termination was this the right decision
should the Security Council have voted
to authorize pardon me this use of force
or was the state or organization that
use force doing so wrongly illegally and
this be made part of the public record
at some point others have been tempted
to say well why don't we have something
stronger why don't we go lock them up at
the ICC you know if they have committed
a crime of this sort you know in another
world that might be attractive but we
don't live in that world no matter what
George Bush is doing he's not going to
be arrested sense of the hegh and tried
Norwood Putin Norwood who's in town nor
would any of the great powers the best
we can do and it's not enough is
publicity that is a little bit of
shaming better information and hoping
that that will deter some of the rash or
uses of force so my argument is that we
need to put together in a balanced view
an assessment of lethality likelihood
legitimacy proportionality deliberation
everything in it and legality and come
to some comprehensive view of each
particular case as to whether it can be
justified it's murky granted but it's I
think the best we can do and better than
the alternatives that we have in front
of us in the book I went on to show in
some cases then why it was that the
deliberation in the Security Council on
South Africa was in my view both
legitimate and legal when they imposed
forcible sanctions on South Africa
having to do with the import of arms
there was good reasons for this they
were both humanitarian and preventive it
was a classic instance a model of the
Security Council behaving well and then
in the book I go on to show that even
though they were illegal under
international law the the blockade that
is the quarantine of Cuba could be
presented I think reasonably as a
justified use of force given the nature
of the threats at the time it's a
complicated argument and I make a case
that Israel's use of force against Iraq
in 1981 where in a surgical strike they
blew up the osai wreck reactor given the
circumstances of that time illegal as it
was was also barely a justified use of
in a preventive way where I want to
conclude is to just do a hypothetical
for you two hypotheticals what
preemption looks like what prevention
looks like and then wrap up with a
comment on on Iraq let me give you these
hypothetical on preemption first of all
here's the hypothetical the president
gets word that an aircraft has been
hijacked by terrorists they have a
radioactive bomb on board and are
heading toward an American city this to
my mind is the beginning of what can
constitute a clear act of unilateral
Carolinian preemption that is it's fully
covered by the inherent right of
self-defense an article 51 of the UN
Charter the president can act to protect
the US including shooting down the
airliner if it's tragically the only
option that might have might stop this
attack and the president can do so
without consulting the Security Council
and indeed I think in US law without
even consulting the Congress this is the
responsibility of the commander-in-chief
to act under these circumstances of an
airliner flying in American city with a
radioactive bomb on board that's a clear
case of preemption let me give you what
then my standards look like for a
hypothetical on prevention looking
farther over the horizon towards an
emerging threat that's not imminent
there's no plane flying it in any
American city the president obtains
reliable intelligence that a terrorist
group is purchasing materials to
construct chemical or biological or
radioactive dirty bombs the group has
announced its determination to attack to
harm the United States and in the past
has acted on that by for example
attacking US embassies abroad blowing
them up there the host country harbors
this group this terrorist group and it's
shown it's been unwilling to do anything
to arrest or even control them the
president in this scenario should bring
the threat to Congress he should bring
the information he has where a real
debate should take place in closed
session or open session and he should
request an authorization to act that is
to take this to the Security Council he
should then take it to the Security
Council and request an authorization
from the Security Council to act against
what he will present his ambassador will
present is a clear threat to peace under
Article 39 the US will need to make the
case that the threat is real
well evidenced not controllable by
lesser means including economic
sanctions let us say and that it reaches
the level of lethality and likelihood
that warrant action and that both the
terrorists in the harboring state are in
clear violation of international law
that's the kind of an argument that
would need to be made before the
Security Council in a good world the
Security Council would endorse this
argument assuming everything that I've
said so far is true and authorized a
preventive action that could be taken at
some point in the future at an opportune
moment in an ideal world the harboring
state having seen the Security Council
warrant basically addressed against
itself would wake up to its dangers and
arrest the terrorists and send them off
to the Hague for trial but in a much
less good world here's where the
scenario becomes more problematic one or
more of the permanent members of the
Security Council would veto that
Security Council authorization even
though it's have I've hypothesized it's
based on the good merits of the case and
the past practice should have led those
members to authorize that act of
prevention the president then having
been turned down by Security Council
should go back to Congress and ask for a
declaration of war after a last round of
diplomacy with his host country the
United States is about to come down upon
them heavily he then is in the position
that the host country does not respond
and there's no less harmful way of
dealing with the threat to take what
might be a necessary act of force
provided it's done with all due and
necessary regard for non-combatants and
proportional surgical away as possible
and he could therefore order a surgical
strike on this terrorist group to avoid
the danger that's being posed by that
group putting those weapons into
American cities having done that the
president should commission a study that
will look back over the intelligence
that he's been working with
and be able to do another look to see
whether or not it was justified and the
Security Council should turn around and
Commission an International Commission
to look into the justifiability
and assess the responsibility the
responsibility for the state that acted
in the United States in this
hypothetical and the responsibility of
those who did not support why they did
not support an authorization if it was
legitimate quest for authorization so
those are the two with two scenarios one
legitimate preemption and the other in
my mind legitimate prevention let me
conclude with the last remark on Iraq if
he illustrates what I think that is the
attack on Iraq in March 2003 an
unlimited response an invasion and
regime change to Iraq's record of real
human rights of bruce's mix compliance
with Security Council resolutions and
employing those for ELLs those criteria
the attack on Iraq did not meet my my
criteria of a legitimate act of
prevention Saddam Hussein's record of
aggression against his neighbors was
real he invaded them more than twice his
human rights abuses were real there was
no question about that record including
genocide in two instances his failure to
fully cooperate with the Security
Council and disarmament verification was
real and he was he was therefore on all
of those grounds presenting a reasonable
threat most of course to his neighbors
but more broadly to the world everything
I've described so far justified a
continuation of inspections and the
extensive sanctions that were placed
upon Iraq indeed one could go further
and I think it would also I would say
that it justified the desert fox attacks
on Iraq that took place the air attacks
in 1998 they were designed to prevent a
significant upgrading in the iraqi air
defense system that he was in the
process of doing with chinese
underground communications and it would
made it very difficult if not impossible
to enforce the no-fly zones and the
sanctions on Iraq so I think that those
pinpoint attacks on the Iraqi defense
system in nineteen
by the Clinton administration we're
justified but what they were justified
in doing is keeping in place the
preventive regime that the Security
Council had established in 1991 a legal
form of international prevention that
was designed to prevent Iraq from
becoming a power armed with deliverable
weapons of mass destruction
now this regime was far from perfect
those of you who followed have known it
had way too many that is the sanctions
regime way too many collateral
implications for innocent Iraqis and it
needed to be adjusted and it was being
adjusted so that there'd be less harm to
innocent Iraqis more medicine would be
available a food would be better
available there would be jobs that could
be done while side of the saying was
prevented from acquiring weapons of mass
destruction I could describe that more
length if you wanted to in March 2003
however the lack of evidence that that
Saddam Hussein was successfully
developing nuclear weapons or could not
be deterred from using chemical or
biological weapons made an escalation to
a forcible attack unjustifiable other
charges that he was in league with
al-qaeda lacked credible evidentiary
support and further deliberation would
have revealed the weaknesses of the
arguments that were made by the US
government in short there was nothing
new in March of 2003 that required a
revision of the existing regime of legal
Prevention authorized by the Security
Council in 2000 1991 invasion and
occupation were disproportionate and
unjustifiable the legality of the
invasion was unclear there were past
Security Council resolutions that might
lead you that interpretation but an
equally good or if not better
interpretation is a Security Council has
to authorize specifically every use of
force you can't just take an old license
and use it but what was clear was that
the lethality and likelihood of the
threat had not changed and any any
remarkable degree any significant degree
and legitimate proportionality therefore
way
against any change in the prevention
regime changing from the regime in place
of sanctions and and against him
authorised by the national community to
an invasion and an occupation so let me
conclude here in the lectures I gave it
in the book of striking first my aim is
to propose standards of international
prevention focusing on lethality
likelihood legitimacy and legality and
explore their usefulness in contentious
cases I am fully aware that those four
ELLs provide no immediate ready recipe
life and death and national security do
not lend themselves to these recipes at
best they are an invitation to improve
the deliberation and of course that's
what I very much expect to continue okay
thank you I'd welcome any my pleasure
yes please
when the Iranian speedboats were buzzing
around
that is exactly the aim I don't want to
oversell it you know I don't think
there's no way that we can prevent in in
the strongest terms being manipulated
political actors have a lot of interest
to manipulate us but I think that we are
better off if we have developed a set of
questions that they need to address
number one and that's what I'm trying to
do through these standards if we've
developed some case law you know okay
you know if you agreed with me that the
Cuban Missile Crisis quarantine was
legitimate
here are the circumstances that made it
so or if you agree the Security Council
made the right decision to impose
sanctions on South Africa here are the
circumstances that made it so and we can
refer back to those and thirdly and
lastly if we've created procedures that
you have to go through you've got to
check off the box you've got to take it
to the Security Council you can't just
say oh they wouldn't have agreed with me
you've got to put on the record reasons
and you have to have you know that
they're going to be investigated
afterwards by a national commission and
an international commission these are
the the the basis for hoping that it
becomes more difficult to manipulate us
but I would never say that we can't be
manipulated you know we we will
unfortunately my hope is that the less
of a chance with these kind of standards
then if we stuck with either Caroline or
Security Council and didn't try to
develop standards to fill in how the
Security Council should debate and how
we should make that decision if we are
trying to make a case the Security
Council acted irresponsibly and there
are plenty of instances like the ones
you mentioned in my in the book I have a
quote from Abraham Lincoln where he's
taking on polecat exactly in that case
that you're talking about about the
dangers of just relying on the President
as a source of information
and he was insisting that this be
subject to full deliberation in the
Congress in this particular case yes
please yes
right okay on on the acai raccattack for
me it's it's right on the margin it's
clearly illegal I don't there's any
debate well there's a little bit of
debate but not much the balance of the
evidence suggests that it was an illegal
attack but I regarded as justifiable in
the following ways it would have been
better of course if Israel had gone to
the Security Council and got an
authorization put forth the evidence
that it had loved the dangers posed by
side of the sane and his nuclear program
but that was unrealistic at that time I
still would have preferred that happen
but Israel could not accept expect
rather a fair hearing in 1981 at the UN
Security Council in the middle of the
Cold War and given its conflict with its
neighbors so I'd rule that out but there
was evidence at the time both from a
number of different sources that Saddam
Hussein was expressing in in his policy
and night of the government sort of a
genocide Allah threat to Israel again it
was sort of the equivalent of the wipe
them off the map number one number two
he had a concerted program that was
dedicated to acquiring the plutonium
that would it would take of tone ium and
enriched uranium to make a bomb
there was no the way you could explain
the Osiris reactor other than that it
wasn't just a research reactor all of
there was a whole series of measures
which I outlined in a long footnote that
look as this is a dedicated bomb
building program the problem is if the
Israeli said well why don't we
sort of wait until he you know it's got
missiles and deliverable the threat is
greater the problem there it might be
too late that is that once this reactor
went online it couldn't be destroyed
because if you blow up an online reactor
a few miles from Baghdad you yourself of
committed genocide you would have spread
the kind of fallout that would be a
horrendous war crime so they had a
choice of acting now and cutting off
this program when they could do so at
some loss you know there was a French
civilian who was working in there who
was killed and a number of Iraqis in the
nightshift who were killed when the bomb
went in but that was vastly less than
what would happen if they bombed this
when they waited longer the question
whether this accelerated of the Saddam
Hussein's determination to get a nuclear
weapon yes it certainly did that's it in
his own mind he tried to speed things up
but in the meantime this attack had
alerted the French the Americans and
others to the danger and a covert
program was put around to try to prevent
him from getting it so he tried to
accelerate he raised the budget for
example for his nuclear program but
whether or not actually he was moving
quicker than he would have but would
have moved if a siren did left in place
is an open-ended question and
fortunately I think for all of us he did
not develop a deliverable nuclear weapon
by 1991 he invaded Iraq so in that case
on balance I think that it was the right
thing for Israel to have done in those
circumstances yes please
if if there were an equivalent if the
Israeli if the Israeli government were
announcing that they plan to blast away
all of Iraq you know and destroyed the
Iraqi people or the Iraqi religion I
think Israel would have put itself in
the circumstances that it would be
vulnerable in a moral sense to that kind
of attack and that's why statesmen
should not rashly make threats that are
going to eliminate people so that's
that's the case on the other on the
other case of the of the standards and
great power ability willingness to ride
roughshod over them you know I don't
want to say to you here because I don't
I don't believe it myself
that you know if I had written this book
in 2001 and it got wonderful reviews and
everybody says yes that's a good idea
that would have prevented the Iraq war
you know it's just the real world of
politics is such that statesmen will
pursue their interest in ways that are
very hard to contain the only thing that
I would want to argue is that this is
nonetheless a worthwhile endeavor that
we should make it as difficult for them
as as as we can to engage in exploitive
activity we can't we're not gonna be
able to prevent everyone but we should
make we should make sure that the
minimum we embarrass them and this might
put more pressure on if there were
established standards it wouldn't have
just been senator Byrd and congressman
Kucinich who made really good arguments
in the in the in the in the in the
Senate in the house and they did it
would been all the other senators know
well some of whom were running for
president who would hopefully if these
were widely thought to be the kind of
standards they might have stood up a
little bit taller in that debate and in
the Security Council it would have been
better questions they would have insist
upon a set of meetings some in some in
off the record some on the record
maybe our NATO allies would have
demanded full briefing then they got
from secretary Powell again it still
could have happened this administration
was determined to go to war you may know
some of the history
well in September the 12th of 2001 that
is the day after the attack on the World
Trade Center Cheney and Rumsfeld will
talk about let's go get Iraq that this
is weird so there was a strange fixation
on Iraq that took place and I'm not sure
that could have been prevented but my
hope is we have made it more difficult
and it won't prevent every bad more in
the future again the hope is it'll make
it a bit more difficult yes right in the
back yes please when you're on your
second question a lot of these standards
are very close to the standards that
have been advanced for humanitarian
intervention if you were interested you
probably heard resonances with the
Kosovo report
you know legitimate but illegal
describing the Kosovo intervention and
the criteria that they developed there
are ones that are related to these and
in the footnotes of the book I mentioned
some of these connections which you're
identifying the responsibility to
protect doctrine which is a doctrine of
humanitarian intervention is also not
unrelated to the kinds of standards here
and we're all borrowing from just war
standards that go back for centuries so
in answer to your question yes secondly
in in practical terms you know often
prevention mixes with humanitarian
concerns number one exploitative ly so
to go back to Iraq as you may remember
that the administration when there were
no weapons they then said this is this
is you know this is liberating the Iraqi
people it's stopping all the oppression
they're mixed together in in in in
justifiable ways this really interesting
case of the Security Council sanctions
against South Africa
1977 exactly mixed prevention and
humanitarian concerns right there's four
elements to the resolution that was
passed they have to do with the denial
of human rights to the majority
population in South Africa and the great
harms that are being done to them
regularly by the police and others and
attacks that are taking place by South
Africa on the neighboring frontline
states and the South African drive to
acquire nuclear weapons all of these are
mentioned in the one resolution mixing
prevention with humanitarian concerns I
think that often happens in world
politics exploitative ly so sometimes
for propaganda purposes but also really
so in many cases and this and this is
one case not always but in those cases
I'm not an expert on on Darfur
we had a great teaching here at Yale on
Darfur around last year I presumed that
you've kept up the debate going on but
my reason that I regard this is not a
clear-cut case for humanitarian
intervention and not even as clear as
Kosovo which was which is nothing's 100%
clear is the the serious problem within
the Darfur in opposition that is we have
harms being inflicted not just by the
government in Sudan in that's in
Khartoum and their support for the
Janjaweed but within the opposition we
have some that have agreed to peace
others that are not and various of these
factions are victimizing the people in
the region it's not even clear whether
who is the target if there was a
humanitarian intervention you might have
to wind up fighting all the factions in
order to establish law and order and in
my view that would not be viable you
can't have everybody be your enemy and
succeed in a humanitarian intervention
so for those reasons I think it's
problematic it might it might get to
that that is it might condemn it might
emerge to the point that it worked there
was clear enough that one would have
identifiable enemies and friends but at
the present time it seems to me too
confusing to say that this is a case
where we should be using force other
than through it and
peacekeeping operation which should be
put on the ground number two let's at
least try it we've already got
authorized that is we should
logistically build up this operation to
its authorized strength to see if it
actually can deter some of these attacks
right now we're at less than a third of
authorized strength and it's not doing
much good at own well I think that we
should we should help them create a
peace we should help them come to peace
with their neighbors and engage in
conflict resolution to bring together
the Iraqi factions into some viable
sustainable government and then perhaps
have a multilateral presence to help
them put their country back together
right now we conceive of even some of
the opposition candidates in the u.s.
election conceived of this as a
counterterrorism counterinsurgency issue
we should rethink it as a conflict
resolution issue we should try to
discover the terms that will bring
together the major factions the various
Shia factions Sunni factions Kurdish
factions Turkmen factions we should have
a great big peace process along the
lines that the UN organized for
Afghanistan they took everybody to Bonn
and got you know 30 or 40 factions in
the room and they mediated an agreement
that they thought they could live with
with a lot of a little bit of outside
pressure some gentle not so gentle
mostly financial and they created an
arrangement that's what we should try to
do I think that's where we should
refocus our efforts so the best thing
that we could do for Iraq is to help
them number one come to peace and run
their own government as an independent
country with regard to the distinct
damage there are balls five million
displaced persons and refugees as people
that are displaced within Iraq and a
fled across the border they we actually
owe them I think assistance we shouldn't
let them scramble to survive and
there may be compensation that needs to
be paid for damage done to Iraq that was
in my view at least I'm justifiable and
that we could sort out at the National
Court of Justice or some other venue
that might be willing but it's unlikely
to be willing to take them on such a
tough case yes please you mean in Iraq
war in general yeah you know many wars
have economic motives to them and all of
them have economic consequences I
wouldn't say that the economic motives
are the sole motives in most wars you
know usually you get you know through
Citadis and Hobbes got it right to
Citadis you know the two millennium in a
bit ago you know it's a matter of pride
or honor interest the kind of things
you're talking about and fear those are
the typical motives that show up in most
Wars and I can't think of many wars in
which you don't find all three of those
at work I find them to be pretty
complicated and that includes that
includes the Iraq war and so well that's
certainly the case and in terms of
financing yes indeed you know armies
march on their stomachs they have to
have the financing either borrowed the
way we run our system or paid for three
trips through taxes with regard to
consequences all wars have very serious
economic consequences one of the best
predictors of what makes poor countries
really pours at the VAT Civil War this
is in all parts of the world that's been
incredibly destructive if you look at
what's happened to Sierra Leone Liberia
we could go down the list the civil wars
in those countries been absolutely
destructive of any well-being and in
this country my colleague Joe Stiglitz
at Columbia is estimating the long-run
cost of this war in Iraq for the United
States once you add up everything that
counts
opportunity
caused healthcare cost all of that will
run over two trillion dollars which is
an awful lot of money when you think
about what can be done with two trillion
dollars you realize the tragedy that has
been imposed upon the United States at
least in my opinion yes please
mm-hmm I don't what I think it's a real
issue I you may have as you as you've
heard me mention and as in the book I
talk about congressional authorization a
declaration of war I think we need to be
much more traditional than we have been
and and then I think constitutional in
the way in which we decide to go to war
especially these kinds of if we do
preventive Wars of this sort but I don't
discuss it in length I refer to a number
of others who were writing very good
scholarship on this Bruce Ackerman and
Harold Koh and a number of others have
written on the domestic framework for
the war on terror from the legal point
of view and I find those arguments by
and large persuasive they've covered it
so I just referred to it in his book the
national security Constitution he does
discuss the legitimate framework for
taking decisions on war and peace in the
United States the War Powers Act and the
various other frameworks for this
oh you're talking about domestic laws of
self-defense yes yeah yeah my colleague
George Fletcher has at Columbia Law
School has written a very very good book
on the law and the philosophy underlying
underlying US law on the use of force in
self-defense it's a fascinating book
he's beginning to draw some analogies to
the international level so he would be
the person and many many other criminal
law professors would give that kind of
an argument and there are some analogies
about when you can use force
preemptively or preventively in the US
model penal code for example there's
some discussion of that unfortunately
there there's the turns upon things that
are interested to us in internationally
as well that is whether a fear is a
sufficient justification for the use of
force or only reasonable fear that is
whether you should judge whether
somebody had a reasonable basis for that
fear and this has come up in some really
key cases there was this the the case in
the New York subway in nineteen seven
someone give me that someone's nodding
their you may remember the name but
that's been one that's been debated in
justice way this is a subway vigilante
who went and shot Barney yeah the Getz
case and Fletcher has written a very
interesting book on the Getz case where
he lays out just the kind of issues that
you're raising and the appeals court it
turned upon fear or reasonable fear as
the as the key issue yes please
I wrote a response to McCain but it was
a good response but it wasn't published
I'm all in favor of democracies as a
scholar I'm one of my early work was on
the importance of this what I call the
Democratic peace that is that
democracies tend to maintain peace with
each other so I'm a I'm a notoriously
pro-democratic with a small D in that
regard but I don't buy into the McCain
league of democracies because he regards
this as you were beginning to elaborate
I think as an alternative to the
Security Council if we don't like the
answer there we go there and they they
can they can authorize whether we've
gone Security Council or not he regards
them as an equivalently legal legitimate
framework for authorizing force I think
that's a a bad model I think the
Security Council should be the court of
first resort number one because it is
legal and that makes a difference to me
that this is in the UN Charter and
number two I think it really makes a
difference that you're able to persuade
countries other than ones that are sort
of birds of your own feather that you
face a serious danger now if you get
vetoed then you have to go someplace
else if it's an illegitimate veto but
the very act of having to persuade
others that are not
fellow card-carrying members of the
democracy club I think will provide
better jurisprudence and better
decisions apart from that you know one
of the other reasons why I don't like
the leak of democracy other than that
dimension of it is that most of the
world's problems are not among the
democracies and we want to solve the
problems if we're gonna deal with
climate change you know Germans are
already on born French are doing okay so
are the British Japanese are ahead in
the right direction until we can
persuade the Chinese that there's a
common set of rules that we can work
forward in the future where had no
chance of dealing with the climate
change so we have to negotiate with
China on climate change others too and
we have to bear most of the burdens
because we've messed up the planet but
we have to get China on board and so you
can't deal with most of the real
problems of the world just by talking to
fellow democracies my question is this
regard is perverse you could you could
work your way one could work one's way
down let's suppose just to sharpen
what's at issue here let's suppose
president McCain and you could say well
by the Doyle doctrine there's a pretty
good case for Iran to act preventively
against the United States
the country waffle with a track record
of attacking countries in the region
mm-hmm
this is a country which talked about
everyone would be next mm-hmm it's now
being led by another Republican
president who has made it clear that he
thinks he wants a real ad openly
advocated that the United States exactly
want mm-hmm legitimacy well you could
imagine some perception of the necessity
on that part this is something that's
residency you could imagine in their
national security circles and you could
imagine that they would try to think up
some sort of proportionate response
mm-hmm to the danger as they perceive it
mm-hmm and you know weapons of the weak
might require that it would be some sort
of what they would think of this
guerrilla action and we might think of
this terrorist action movement and then
finally you could imagine them going to
the Security Council I'm not getting in
here right
seeing themselves as having exhausted
the relevant international flora and
therefore going instead to some other
forum that they would think could be a
substitute you know
they've tried your first resort whoa
okay that's a good that's a great
comment I have a few responses to that
number one the first response is that if
you're an American president you
shouldn't threaten to wipe by the
countries off the map unless you're
prepared to walk into that kind of
danger so my first response as a Doyle
doctrine list would be to say to
president Kane it's hard for me to say
that he should not make those kinds of
threats and there are some threats on
the table that are that are already been
made by some members administration
there they are threats that mostly have
turned upon Iran will not become a
nuclear power which I which is not an
unreasonable concern for the u.s. to
have I think it's a reasonable concern
but there are others that have sort of
laced that with regime change notions
that I think would carry some of the
installations of a threat not as strong
as I Medina jods threats against Israel
or some of his neighbors but still in
that direction so the first lesson from
the Doyle doctrine is don't make threats
that you don't plan and want to live up
to that's a lesson for president McCain
that's the first thing I would say so
that's the first advice this is good
advice for the u.s. president unless you
really do plan to invade Iran don't go
running around saying you might do so
it's dangerous talk is costly the second
advice to let's assume that Ahmadinejad
is still in office if he were ever
prepared to
but listen to advice though I should
mention that when he visited Colombian
had a very uncomfortable time he offered
an invitation to the Columbia faculty to
come to Tehran and give a lecture so I
guess I have an invitation already if I
take him up on that but if I were to
take him up on it the advice that I
would give him is that this is a very
bad idea
you know America is a little threatening
it's certainly dangerous you may try
some of this deliberation but when it
comes to rationality and proportionality
it's very hard to think of any way that
you could eliminate the American threat
in a legitimate way what would you have
to do to the United States to eliminate
this threat and the answer is nothing
that Iran could do indeed what Iran
would do if it attacked us in any way it
would produce its own destruction so in
that regard to be irrational if the
Iranian sent over bombers to New York or
Washington with their own fingerprints
all over it you can be sure that the US
would retaliate and unfortunately
disproportionally and so for an Iranian
president he would be signing his and
his country's death warrant
though he should he should never do it
so my advice to us is don't provoke them
unless we have unless we really plan to
do something and we don't in my view
have a justification for anything other
should I should take a step back and
that is that I do support the current
Security Council sanctions against Iran
I think that they pose significant Iran
poses enough of a danger to its
neighbors that the current sanctions
against elements of the Iranian weapons
apparatus and the security apparatus is
legitimate these are talking focus on
particular individuals preventing them
from travel and preventing the sale of
weapons to Iraq I think those are
legitimate but any other action beyond
that I think it's unjustified at the
present time and so the McCain don't
make those threats to Ahmadinejad don't
launch an attack on the United States
would follow for my doctrine even though
you might be tempted to do so in your
less sane moments that would get you
into a lot of trouble so that would be
my response